Obamacare have you heard they're having
some problems the rollout has been a
disaster websites not working something
like six people signed up on the first
day and now it turns out maybe the
president lied about how it's all gonna
work let's go to the videotape you can
keep your plan if you are satisfied with
it if you like the plan you have you can
keep it if you like your plan and you
like your doctor you won't have to do a
thing you keep your plan if you like
your health care plan you will be able
to keep your health care plan if you've
got health insurance you can keep it if
you like your health care plan you will
keep your plane if you've got health
insurance do you like your doctor you
like your plan you can keep your doctor
you can keep your plan if you have
insurance that you like then you will be
able to keep that insurance if you like
your doctor or healthcare plan you can
keep it if you like your health care
plan you can he keep your health care
plan if you like your health care plan
you can keep it or something like that
yeah okay there's many more examples of
that we've all seen it we've been
talking about this on the show for a
while now I believe that Obamacare is
something that is important to the
country people should have a right to
universal health care all that good
stuff but the rollout is a disaster and
Obama on Monday explained a little bit
about what he really meant when he was
saying all that other stuff now if you
have or had one of these plans before
the Affordable Care Act came into law
and you really like that plan what we
said was you could keep it if it hasn't
changed since the laws passed so we
wrote into the Affordable Care Act
you're grandfathered in on that plan but
if the insurance company changes it then
what we're saying is they've got to
change it to a higher standard they've
got to make it better they've got to
improve the quality of the plan that
they're so okay so that seems like a
pretty big if there was no if before
that right so my first question to you
guys is this his sort of George Bush no
new taxes Bill Clinton I did not have
sexual relations with
woman moment this is really a semantic
argument I mean if he came out of just
said hey you know we we misspoke the
issue really is that these healthcare
plans are now meeting a new standard so
if if these people are losing their
health care plans they're going to have
to pay more it's because they're going
to end up with better coverage so maybe
they paid 50 bucks before but if they
ended up having a detrimental disease
god forbid cancer they weren't going to
have the coverage that they needed or
deserved as especially now under
Obamacare right so his argument is that
the lowest standard is going to be
raised now so that if you lost your
health care plan you're actually gonna
get a better one but if he lied his way
into this why should we believe that but
did he really lie this is that not a lie
so that's what everyone's saying did he
willfully lie is this is deception is
this did they not really tell him the
truth so he didn't know what he was
gonna say look when you're campaigning
you have to find something snappy and
snazzy to say and I guarantee you will I
am or some hip hop artist is gonna use
that is going to sample that now it's
going to be dropped into the next you
know whatever the summer tune is gonna
be you know if you keep it you can have
it like that you can do it and then
they're gonna take Obama's campaign
basically slogan and use it now because
it's catchy right it's catchy you can't
say if you like your health you know a
care plan you can keep it although
parentheses and inks exclamation and
here's what we have and hold on there's
more to it Astra's ok I just want to say
all that I totally agree with you I
think that's what happened here I think
he knew that a certain amount of people
were gonna be kicked off their plan and
the hope was they were all gonna get
better insurance as you're saying right
but does isn't there some issue with the
the trust that we all want to trust this
guy there something different about
Obama and I think people really want to
trust him and believe in him so when he
lies just for the campaign purposes I
think this somehow seems a little worse
we can't me what I like she says we
can't even really call it a lie that
it's really more of it was easier just
to say this and not do all the
explanations on the background but if he
came out and said hey you know what we
misspoke we're sorry you're going to get
better health care and change is hard
but once you
get into it and once you see that you're
going to have better coverage then
people are going to forgive him we're
very forgiving people and we have very
very short term memories now so if he
just came out talked about it honestly
said hey look once we started once we
pass this bill and so many people so
many changes were made to it yeah all of
this all of this has changed the way
this all works but you're gonna have
better coverage in the long run people
are going to thank him I think for that
later on but accepting the change is the
hardest part because it's hard it's hard
to change it regard to change your plan
if you liked it because it was cheap but
if it didn't give you coverage what's
the point of even paying and in expand
for an inexpensive plan right so then
the real question here is can you
believe after he makes the initial miss
truth or what do we want to call it
kimya word the rap lyric the rapper that
you were alluding to right can we then
by his next statement which is
everybody's is going to get better
because doesn't that seem a little how
often does that happen in government or
in anything we're going to do something
and everybody is gonna get a better
situation how do I look I love my
insurance plan that I have right I have
a 7000 all deductible and you know I
don't get any kind of you know
prescription stuff because I don't take
drugs but you know it's awesome like I
don't have any extra eye care or dental
which is perfect because those only
things I really care about so other than
that I really love my plan but if you
don't like your plan and you may be you
know call 911 now it's going to be
covered and it's hard to explain all
that to most of America you know I'm
talking to and they don't get that if
your plan doesn't have let's say
maternity you know leave or things like
that or like emergency things that come
up you're going to now have it is just
going to be basic for everyone yeah you
will have the basic things I think he
should have said if you like it you're
gonna like it more right that's what he
should said why is why are they not
calling me Frank's campaign stuff I
don't know if you could write it well
you only have consulted him and saved
him a lot of heartache right and if you
would've said that it would have been as
catchy cuz if you like it you can keep
it period is just like perfect right adt
nation say if you like it you can put a
ring on it you should have done a little
dance with it
oh and I think that would have worked
yeah so then my final question on this
is do you guys think that in general you
know philosophic sense do you think the
ends justify the means if he had to do
this sort of trickery or lie or whatever
we want to call it to get this thing
passed and at the end it's going to be
good and more people will have coverage
and better coverage do the ends justify
the means to the lie and the Miss truth
justify everyone getting something
better in the end if we're going on the
assumption it's going to be look all
terrains now that people can now get
genetic screaming for things like cancer
and it has to be covered if people
aren't going to be dropped because they
get sick or because they have a
pre-existing condition that is a big big
change and that's a really awesome thing
but people won't really understand it
until they have to really go until they
have that experience and a lot of people
to try to answer don't even know I know
what you're saying until you're almost
dying from lung cancer then you'll be
like oh I get it now I like it and I
like it more right so you think the ends
do justify the means that thinks so he
omitted and I know you were saying
something about semantics and I don't
know what Jews have to do with it but
omitted information that just would have
been too long to get into right right a
sticker a bumper sticker that that's all
you have time for slogans rest of it
people would again short attention spans
people would have tuned out to the rest
of it but what's the new Obamacare you
get better attention spans because now
you have an doctor that can take care of
your attention yeah yeah what's the
a.d.d medication I keep forgetting I
don't know clearly a matter on that role
as you can see all right well then I I
kind of think that the ends don't
necessarily justify the means if you
screwed up the process even if you get
something good out of it but that's what
makes the world go around